le rachat de ce fleuron de l'industrie
militaire française on en parle tout de
suite avec françois souvent si général
de brigade expert en géostratégie
général bienvenu merci d'être avec nous
alors première question est ce que c'est
bien ce rachat par les américains je ne
sais pas si on peut dire que c'est bien
je trouve ça inquiétant
nous sommes dans le débat sur la
souveraineté nationale d'une part sur la
maîtrise de notre industrie d'armement
d'autre part et si on se mettait au
niveau de gier est justement de la
géostratégie
nous avons des exemples américains qui
ont entravé les exportations françaises
soit 130 d'armement comme le rafale en
particulier où dès lors qu'il y à un
matériel dix américains de production
américaine
nous ne pouvons plus exportés comme nous
l'entendons donc la notion de
souveraineté me paraît essentiel et je
sais que c'est une affaire qui dure
depuis des mois
ce rachat et ça pose la question
effectivement du maintien de cette
souveraineté souveraineté technologique
française et est ce que les américains
on doit les autoriser à acheter nos
entreprises alors je sais pas si on va
les autoriser moi en tout cas il ya
aucun français qui s'est positionné sur
le marché il ya bruno le maire qui
essaient de pousser thales a racheté
faut donner mais personne donc aucune
industrie française n'a pour l'instant
fait d'offre tout à fait c'est
inquiétant et je me pose toujours la
question titre personnel où est le
patriotisme économique notamment chez
nos entreprises nous voyons que ça
appartient ces entreprises et étages
avait été acheté par un fonds français
donc déjà on pouvait espérer qu'un fonds
dits d'investissement puisse avoir un
français puissent avoir un sens
patriotes effectivement une entreprise
doit pas perdre d'argent mais dès lors
qu'on est leader
saab sont bizarres que ne soit pas
capable d'avoir des marges financières
suffisantes et une production économique
suffisante pour une telle entreprise
donc oui les entreprises ne sont pas
très intéressés elles font peut-être
monter les enchères
mais dans tous les cas nous sommes dans
une sur une question de souveraineté
nationale
il serait complètement anormal que cette
entreprise nous échappe
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire que ces
entreprises justement ne parle ne pense
pas forcément patriotisme économique
comme
et si bien mais plutôt business si tout
à fait mon sentiment comme dans beaucoup
d'autres cas nous avons effectivement la
logique de la financiarisation
d'économie de la recherche de la
rentabilité
et puis finalement à directement une
accepte la dépendance nos armements
aujourd'hui pour l'exportation comme je
disais il ya quelques instants ne
peuvent pas comprendre du matériel
américain ou des pièces américaines ou
si elles sont cette situation là les
américains peuvent mettre un veto sur
l'exportation
donc on se met sous la coupe des états
unis par action indirecte d'une
entreprise américain concrètement au
niveau de la défense comment ça peut se
traduire si photonis était bel et bien
racheté par des américains je me demande
comment vont faire nos armées
aujourd'hui le la ministre des armées
s'est exprimée ou le ministère s'est
exprimé sur la question il ya quelques
temps en disant qu'elle cherchait
une solution pas qu'il cherchait une
solution et des certain que la question
de défense nationale d'une part et
d'économie d'autre part pourrait être
dissociés dans l'absolu mais dans la
réalité il faut bien être une solution
est-ce que nous pouvons dépendre d'une
une entreprise sous contrôle américain
donc je crois que fillon qu'il faut
trouver une solution que le ministre des
armes l'ami désarmé à une obligation de
résultat mais aussi bercy puisque le
maire s'est exprimé sur la question il
connaît bien les questions de défense
je pense qu'il cherche la solution de
sortie il faut pas non plus désespérée
ce qu'a dit bruno le maire se il ya
quelques jours c'est quand même ce sont
des rumeurs
ce rachat par une entreprise américaine
donc à la limite on pourrait penser que
solution sera trouvée
justement il l'a rappelé un que cette
vente si jamais elle était faite avec
des américains et pouvait être encadré
avec des engagements justement qu'ils
imposeraient aux américains est ce que
c'est possible de me dire voilà on vous
le vent mais en même temps dans le cadre
quand même ce qui va se passer on peut
le dire maintenant quelques cas où
justement ça a été dit ça a été signé ce
n'a pas été appliquée donc quelle
confiance accorder dans une intel accord
ce sera peut-être dab sur deux ans trois
ans puis dans quatre ou cinq ans
qu'est-ce qui se passera si jamais il ya
un problème
donc je crois pas que ces garanties
suffisantes nous sommes dans la
communication politique
comme d'habitude pour faire accepter la
vente éventuelle date l entreprise je ne
crois pas qu'il fasse faire confiance
aux accords même aussi stricte que le
ministre veut bien les annoncer alors il
me semble que l'état ont peu de parts
dans ben taleb est ce que c'est possible
que bruno le maire force un peu la main
à thales pour racheter justement
photonis voilà je peux pas répondre
je dirais que mon sentiment c'est oui
mais thales est aussi quand même une
entreprise privée elle est là pour faire
des bénéfices pour vendre donc oui
l'état a une influence sur thales comme
sur d'autres entreprises je crois que ça
feront aussi avait été sollicité pour
prendre cette entreprise sont sous son
aile donc je pense que la solution sera
trouvée et mais d'un autre côté je crois
que plus on parlera de cette situation
de perte de souveraineté dans un domaine
sensible
de plus on a une chance d'aboutir un
résultat français sinon européen sait-on
jamais rappelons nous quand même sur le
théâtre des opérations puisque c'est
ainsi dans l'armement que aujourd'hui
sur les théâtres d'opération est capable
de voir la nuit c'est être capable de
gagner un combat ce qui n'est pas donné
à tout le monde donc perdre une telle
compétence est grave
donc je pense qu'il faut effectivement
se battre pour garder son entreprise
dans le giron - français peut-être
européen général je rappelle que vous
êtes général de brigade et expert en
géostratégie merci d'avoir été avec nous
je remercie